um quite a bit of the agenda so I'm just
gonna make a start so I have no
apologies from from anyone from any
exactly and do we have an even apologies
uh councilor acting incentives apologies
for this evening thank you very much
Alex and likewise item two there's I've
not received any Declarations of
Interest
now okay and if we go on to item three
the minutes of the meeting held on the
24th of July 2023 I'm happy to do the
there
accurate correct record of that meeting
I was all those in favor
thank you and now questions sorry item
four which is questions from the public
we've received four questions this
evening three from Mr Chris boys and one
from Mr Andrew gold and as per last time
round I am going to pass over to Anna
our legal officer in the room to ask the
question why thank you chair the first
question is regarding
Street trading in the sale Town Center
from Mr Chris boys and he asks does the
provision of a non-food pitch license
limit the size of the pitch so to walk
ground area Does it include or exclude
the inclusion of space for the parking
of an Associated commercial vehicle and
if so to what area and Does it include
or exclude the ability to extend the
retail area taken to include parts of
the city installed for the benefit and
enjoyment of the public at Large
foreign
[Music]
using it and does not cause nuisance
solenoids it is not proposed to have
fixed pitch sizes other than those
already marked out around Manchester
United football ground and the
Lancashire printing Club when
determining an application for a license
offices will considered pitch size on a
case-by-case basis taking you into
account the size of the unit articles
being sold football location and nature
of the area other trading activities
would have to take place within the
designated pay and any other Associated
items such as tables chairs or
commercial vehicles would not be
permitted similar to the pictures near
the Manchester United ground in
Microsoft
thank you councilor Thompson if we now
move on to question two please Emma
thank you chair question two is also
from Mr Chris boys who wishes to ask the
following question concerning the 2023
tree policy given that it is proposed
that in the future
three inspections will take place on a
three yearly basis but is considerably
more frequently than has been the case
for a number of years please get the
relevant executive member advised by how
many full-time equivalents the workforce
to carry out these inspections will be
increased to accommodate this
improvements to service under what cost
thank you if I pass over now to
counselor outside thank you
the answer of it is that one extra full
time has already been employed to help
implement the councils through the uh
the strategy inspection program at a
cost of 35
000 and the council has also recently
purchased an entry management system
what's that crazy tree is it easy is it
true it would be an end across the
twenty thousand pounds that the new
system enables kiosks to capture
reception data at an increased rate
compared to the other two management
system run ahead and hence assessed with
ongoing inspections
thank you counselor had said and if we
go to question three please
in question three from Mr Chris boys he
asks give a bit in a council meeting
last year an executive member suggested
that to allow for wheelchair users and
Men carers children's bookies Etc the
minimum clearance passageway on
Pavements from Park Vehicles should be
1.8 meters police kind of explanation be
given as to why in the 2023 tree policy
the suggested minimum allowance for new
tree planting should be the Lesser
distance of 1.2 meters
thank you and I'll pass to councilor as
I said for the answer
the reference to a minimum 1.8
Civic in response to factors for the
restoration
six living streets recommendations for
an even closer and placement of new
equipment as previous council meeting
the living Street's recommendations is
suggested to be 1.5 liter or hindered in
the number of circumstances
Twitter
with regard Please Mr Cheese however the
large proportion of existing trees and
especially around for children
unfortunately do not often suggested
removal
[Music]
these trees are then replaced on a two
for one basis with a normal mental
divides it's more suitable for the
highway and are often placed as
alternative sites in a new location to
allow compute access on their empowered
footwork the individual and replacement
of trees in existing locations
particularly on the highway of over
Highway design standards have to
consider your raw crime and
environmental impact of these trees on a
side-by-side basis the suggested put by
which I live in speech therefore is 1.5
meters from England however the legal
minimum square foot Pathways based on
Highway rights or Rehabilitation which
requires one meter
while these standards are different
Stills recommended by the women's Suites
declutter times the tree
to ensure that any placements are
probably new equipment or activities
when captain on the highway will be a
specifically that's effectively applying
1.5
meter to our equivalent to the United
States would say and that would have
would see a different book effects on
crime and environmental
in those things
is considered a fair compromise and
still allow access to given the design
and layout of public space that sets out
in the case they need to be approved
thank you councilor had said and if we
go to another final question this
evening thank you thank you question
four submitted by Mr Andrew Gould as a
member of friends of David Hume Park I
have a keen interest in the outcome of
the seven year review of the one
Trafford contract for a number of years
our group members have been active on
the park essentially getting involved in
many of the drugs that Amy was supposed
to be doing such as weeding beds
clearing leaves adding paths cutting
Hedges clearing ponds and litter picking
we've been told that in the future Amy's
performance will be judged by part
walkabouts but how will Amy be assessed
when maintenance world has been
controlled partially by volunteers
additionally how will the large majority
of parks in Green Space who don't have
an active France group agree an
appropriate SLA and be periodically
assessed
thank you very much I'm presuming this
is to you councilor outside to respond
yes
it's underpin and support these efforts
we are looking to introduce services
and we'll be looking to work through the
SLA in the French groups on an ongoing
basis at local meetings and discuss how
the escalate will be used going forward
as a practical conductive tool in
managing of the problems as well
voluntary working days within our Parks
can also be seen
can also be a celebration of community
within together with a wide range of
benefits this type of voluntary work
tends itself when when's itself
perfectly for cleaning people together
and engage in Horticulture creating
process of reflection and connection a
discipline level developing levels of
understanding and working out the range
the Practical mechanism Corporation and
Joint decision making
[Music]
we're also looking to extend
the SLA Department we don't probably
have
to be established and we'll be coming up
several walking meeting with officers
who are tasked in doing a business
service from these areas of the country
thank you councilor that says if we move
on now to item five which is Matters
from Council or overview in excrucially
committees and Council books uh do you
have anything you wish to raise
just to mention that the health scrutiny
committee formed their task and finish
group on the 5th of September
um look at Social prescribing which is
is about organizations and Community
groups that have a beneficial impact on
residents so looking at Seattle to how
they're operating in these ways
and that's across the whole
thank you very much I'm sure we all look
forward to the uh the outcomes of the
task and finish group so thank you for
being hope you take that now moving on
to item six which is the one traffic
partnership seven year contract review
of guns this is a part one and I'm going
to pass over to councilor ad set to
introduce this report
will be aware when the contract was left
in 2015
retain the provision for a view around
the halfway point is not very close and
always from the message contract this is
a however an opportunity to review
service areas such as service funds
value for money performance
and and makes a good change to literally
changes
for the Pinnacle of this of course is a
house for candidates such as
Communications or internally collector
the opportunity was taken to make
changes it's on surface areas and this
is resulting in significant boom
particularly in Waste Service
collections I'm bringing in the western
unionization team in-house to actually
help Thrive or recycling initiatives and
of course proposal changes through
Christmas collections help enhance the
service over time and build the crew as
much as it's great
all the other technique these proposals
forward again that looks really
important not very much highlights
between spaces and how we will be
working with defense particles help your
social club agreed to return a few
minutes of cash involved in the process
and monitoring working apart and in the
passage Omega part of the problem has
been is that there's been a missile was
coming and from a living perspective
actually what they see as the work that
they would like everyone accountable to
about what they have if you belong to
and the confusion in that and that's led
to the current section what should we
have taken therefore by having these
implantis walking these in Southwestern
Community and defense department were
quite clear what what we will also from
our perspective
the deliverability to ensure that
they're here to the whole
as much as I would like to highlight
many more of these Services I will leave
it there I'm assuming everyone
I would though I take the opportunities
as far as how his team has helped
liability
how much work is actually really gone
into it and you go through some of the
appendices contains in this world you'll
see the details and all the different
working groups and also to demonstrating
that involvement is actually all in that
time so we can feel it it's that is
thank you thank you councilor I've said
I'd also like to Echo my thanks to Chris
Morris and his team
um and everyone that's been involved in
this seven year review it has been a
very big amount of work that's been
undertaken and I am very optimistic
about what we've brought here to the
executive tonight and I know it is
something that councilors cross parties
have all been uh having a keen interest
in because it includes so many Frontline
services that I know are very very
important to our local residents are
there any questions or comments from the
house Williams
thank you I won't speak at any great
length but I did just briefly want to
reflect on what a strong piece of work
having to be undertaken during the seven
year review
um I think everyone is about many
members of the labor group previously
had significant concerns about the
partnership with Amy and I have a call
one of the first things that I've been
elected with participating in the
scrutiny committee that looked at
options regarding the future of the
contract and if you recall the
administration it's recommended by the
committee that they should consider
termination of the contract so I think
it's been totally hands really that
we're now in a position and not only
need to really embrace the continuation
of the contract but also to celebrate
some of the good way that's been
achieved
um and that's been undertaken really by
our offices and by our colleagues at Amy
and I think we should celebrate the
service improvement that we've observed
and it must be but it's just like to
Reflections
partnership board and I think we're
we're at a certain stage in the journey
and we're starting to see degree
insurance is some very exciting activity
indeed and I welcome in particular and
the information you're getting appendix
GA which outlines the journey we started
upon towards the decarbonization of the
Partnerships activities so with that
plan I'm having to score the
recommendations before us this evening
thank you thank you Council Williams
thank you um
[Music]
Council Williams's um statement about
what a more positive place we're at with
this report I think it's a useful reset
of the relationship
and clear to the general public uh
that's been done and what we hope to
achieve just a quick point on the
mention there of the greens um Space
strategy
um there is a gap that we have locally
that that will that will fill in terms
of providing that overarch vision and
aspiration and long-term future for our
green spaces and so I welcome that and
I'll be happy to contribute as I'm sure
many of us will be and the friends with
Parks who do a wonderful job I think
they work really hard and I'm sure that
they'll welcome the the clarity
um around their sort of the nation's
responsibilities and expectations in the
past thank you
thank you and are there any wider
questions councilor Evans
thank you chair and I'd like to come in
Chris Morris and his team it has been a
huge piece of work
um and hopefully it's good to recognize
uh like the members recognizing that
maybe it might be some newness I will
leave it at that and as I haven't gotten
many questions on it it's a case of wait
and see I think with respect to this
renegotiation how a notional issue uh
page 29 9.7 refers to an appendix f
which is about the delivery of the I.T
system given communication has been one
of the major flaws uh of this uh
contract over the years and it'd be
interesting to know when the it system
is planning to be in place and bear in
mind public sector it systems never go
well and I know our partners have had
problems with our it systems doesn't
appears to be an appendix said there is
an appendix e which may be appendix ad
but there's no dates on it whatsoever
and I've got some Noble comments for the
moment I have on part two which you can
help you with appendix F when we will
see the NC system thank you councilor
Evans um councilor outside
communication code communicate or
particularly in relation system I'm not
completely for that obviously
the it itself
particular details that I've made
yeah just to start off with a with an
apology so I think e as referenced but
as a title the candidates he should be
appendix so from the power from the
power board so the lake in the you know
the part title is correct and its
reference on the document itself
and it does link to the person of the
council CRM system that's the drive if
you look at that uh appendix muscle the
white space has been done has been
implemented
um now
which is being worked on what we can
come from yeah
thank you um councilor Ennis
thank you chair you suddenly review
represents something of the landmark
moment in Council of working
relationships today so how successful
does the executive field with the
contract has been so far up and hand on
heart what time it will improvements can
our residents expect to see from any
Services going forward particularly on
highways but also on Parks and green
spaces these are some of the basics that
residents just don't feel uh Trafford is
getting right I just want to
specifically ask in terms of race
collection which I think we are happy to
say have has improved drastically since
the university
do we anticipate any issues coming down
the tracks in terms of race collection
given the government's Rights Management
proposals or Chancellor presented to do
policies with your committee recently
thank you very much for those questions
I'll pass to councilor I've said in
first instance
if you were obviously uh on the last
Point uh
that's what I think it is
obviously uh the government's in a bit
of a state of chaos
reported democracy about the reflected
really don't know what's happened with
that it is difficult for us to actually
find Future planning around those
products issues until we get quality
actually what is actually happening I
mean there are some rumors potentially
that is being pushing along bus life the
Next Generation I can't confirm that he
went past his colleagues but optician
members might be able to confirmware
aspects and what we do but it's
certainly an area where we actually want
to build the last potentially some cues
very good initiatives within those and
they have high reaching effects and
obviously we need to start planning
about Christians of physical planning
and people part of also Financial
Planning and it's putting all these
things into uh
obviously
to compensation how we can actually get
a patient up to its relevant to all
members if you go into our community
that's an area of the airport and that's
actually it's interesting yoga class
obviously uh well we welcome the
improvements in the enemies such as
Waste Services for quite a long time to
get there but as you've seen from
they've brought this competency changes
the way to operate that such as includes
and as you will have seen within that
it's actually a this is a really an
opportunity
um
changes
I've actually seen them from this place
there so I think particularly uh we
welcome both and indeed over the queen
period uh this has led to that much
better relationships with Amy brought as
perhaps a much better Crossing on an
initially many years ago
both sides feel confidently maybe the
contacts account and it would work
successfully so if things aren't
completely perfect we understand that
I'm involving is saying that is the case
and this is particularly made on the
outfit you want to see those changes
to things like highways Green Space and
so forth I'm allowed to do them with any
particular and on an existed resources
and information
the advice would be comparison resources
but obviously we are working in
particularly
Advanced Parts groups are actually
involved in all those types of
the way forward so I know that answers
your questions ever obviously any
particular point on super locations
thank you councilor I said um the the
whole The Wider waste agenda which
we're both familiar with it's looking
like October 2025 well in some of the or
a lot of the changes are proposed for so
it's not it's going to be after a
general election
um once that's uh once up this picked up
um councilor holding two yes
thank you
three questions which I'd like to put
all together and the council I had to
run through them in order
in sectional bins there's a significant
paragraph about the charging policy for
new binge replacement things
Etc what did the legal powers of the
cage happening at that time was that we
now intend to charge people
who come to the council and save me no
longer one to our large group
we want to help you to go back to a
small bit and specifically says that in
the report and I too I'm surprised
second question was no screen spaces and
these serious level agreements
I can't be alone in Majesty that
opposing decision seems to have been
made where impacts which incorporate the
playing fields
by knowing of grass is only being done
on the plane
and several weeks worth of excess growth
around us playing areas have not been
touched and I wonder if that is part of
the greens or whether it's just an
accident
and third and finally a monthly reports
in appendix B are very very impressive
oh do we have any information about what
we've actually done
so far or whether or not registered
um
and just a little aside in the I.T
systems section you're looking for best
interests
I agree very strongly advise against
that because in public sector of I.T
systems best is always always
that's it okay thanks Q uh councilor
Holden um council did you want to make a
start to make sure
the uh
obviously if we're saying that it's
actually working for what you actually
purchase a new largely not produced down
the garage
Council Holden I am supreme you know
English is my first language and I think
that's what it says if I've
misunderstood
foreign
[Music]
um it's a really important
that's introduced early in 2017
obviously charged for all the other
things obviously uh people who have been
getting around
[Music]
so what causes its charge for Amy
writing but if somebody wants to reduce
that and whilst they're into a small job
that is not charged about that I'm aware
of it if I misunderstood that
uh
[Music]
the other one was the monthly report
there are a million examples in the in
the paperwork what we managed to do
because of course so far we have been
reviewing the all the communications
what's happening but particularly once
they're having the appendices I really
made any sort of the Cooperative
proportions out there should we get the
right question numbers
obviously uh we want to make sure that I
have confirmation there so obviously
I'll be discourse seeing that lessons
actually
caught in too many reports at least
make sure that we get the the age of it
was and we have to get more more
positive Facebook all development
information
program s
yeah just to to those reports are mainly
used by the council officer team by our
client team in managing uh aiming to
deliver the contracts they used to have
to look at the input so we've got the
right Staffing numbers and we've got the
right equipment and we get the right
outputs and facility standards and where
they identify where things aren't good
as well as they could based as the
information that helps support that so
some of the things we've talked about
already in terms of improvements into
the West collection service is driven by
our team using the information that
comes out of white space which feeds
into the monthly reports to help them to
address where the service challenges uh
to an example you know that we had a
tweak to the collection there's for a
number of properties we move the number
of properties on their collection
that came out of the information that
came out of this type of work and a
summary of this this goes through to the
one Trafford partnership but which uh
councilor Evans Council really sits on
along the council has chair advantages
as well okay unconscious unconscious
that it's got quite a few questions it
was clearly going to generate a lot of
discussion this particular item
over a bit so I've got counselor Welton
in
India thank you very confused they're um
the partnership boards
suggests that it's the advice areas
council at ads head and there's no place
for Council of Williams that is Council
Williams actually on
on the partnership board okay thank you
very much that's that's good because we
do note the progress for the um on Net
Zero in the report and it's you know
with the uh his portfolio's
responsibility for the future major
highway developments
it's great glad to hear that
um just one more traditional thing we
seem to have um
uh
our old problem with with uh on traffic
seem to be with bins uh biggest problem
certainly locally
um in the Altium area seems to be with
the block grids
um and we should have an Unholy cycle
going on with block grids leading to
build up of of
um
sort of decayed matter Earth which then
leads to more weeds which then leads to
problems with spraying program and
extreme clearance and things like that
um it seems like there needs to be a
rethink of strategy on this to maybe
invest more in clearing the grid so we
don't get so many problems with with
Earth and good places substruct for
weeds to grow are we going to be looking
at that with one traffic going forward
in an operational sense
us obviously working through all things
so we can also shoot the service across
the Visa and the international
agreements actually having move forward
but particularly in boxing performance
and locations
locations I think it is probably many
build competitors where we have vehicles
and I didn't know this weather obviously
and yeah
and then the street cleaning Vehicles
come down and we post it so what we have
in the next in special circumstances
throughout this particular ongoing
problems with those sorts of things
is
so please do dig into the system
property
this type of consistency
yeah just please love that because
obviously obviously
obviously uh that the second year
viewers actually always Tendencies
there's a whole series
so one thing I would say uh after
tonight at the end of the matter really
close actually
relationship domain so we see
improvements over the coming years
that's something that starts to continue
and sustain lots of people because
a lot more changes
look at the service of areas duties
across the Visa post Community groups
and so forth and the key to all depends
Communications
[Music]
Etc
last question
thank you leader a few points that have
sprung to mind while everyone's talking
forgive me it sounded like when you said
earlier we need to develop slas for
green spaces that we've therefore had no
performance measures in place for Amy's
working parks for the last seven years
surely that's not the case councilor
Amsterdam just said a moment ago
actually referred to something that's uh
featured in my life problems with parked
cars where we're trying to unblock grids
and things and he said we have I mean I
heard the word by exception notified
residents in advance before drains are
cleared even in in my short lifetime
this used to be standard practice as a
basic logistical exercise before
undertaking that sort of work so I'm not
sure why that's Now by exception finally
on Council of weapons point I draw your
attention to
um section 7.6 paragraph four I'll read
verbatim the change is because you don't
have to read the beta well it says the
change the customer will also cover the
exchange back to the smaller gray bid
the charge for customers
weapons correct it does say we'll be
charging to go back to the smallest gray
Bill and that is in 7.6 paragraph four
so I'm sorry Council Holden Facebook
in the future to actually change it to a
small bit so somebody to press click at
the moment
then get them in charge by saying we
want a large of it that's been provided
to be a charge but obviously uh at the
wrong sort of a problem have been
charged for that new design
accepting uh
but obviously what we are saying is
actually that changed to a smaller group
in the future is included in that cost
it's quite clear Catherine
is that we're developing these slas
transaction
[Music]
okay
thank you councilor asset so a lot of
discussion and contributions on this
item which is perfectly understandable
because it is one of the most important
things that our residents expect from
ourselves as a council and our partners
at Amy
um counciloranza is quite right this is
this has been a lot of years of work and
effort on behalf of both Memphis and
most importantly our officers
um and I think we've come a long way
we've come a long way from the contract
this Administration inherited in 2018
we've come a certainly a long way from
the contract that was created a few
years before that what this country this
this review seeks to do and I have
confidence that it will do is improve
customer service experience and
engagement it will provide us with
greater transparency
we're going to have improved governments
and governance and performance
monitoring we've got a very very strong
and robust decarbonization agenda which
I think other organizations could
probably learn from work that one
chapter prepared to do in that area
we are going to have a clearer focus on
attracting new capital investment into
Trafford so I feel this is a really good
deal after a lot of discussion against a
continuing context of austerity and very
tight local government finances if
members haven't already done so I would
encourage you to take a visit down to
the depot because you'll get to see
firsthand some of the changes that have
already put in place as a result of
these
including the I.T systems that they use
that and the improvements that we've
seen in the bin service a lot of that is
down to the real-time information that
um that offices down in the depot can
pick up on so if you get the opportunity
to go to the depot take it up it's a
real education I did that earlier this
year I learned a lot about service and
actually the advantage of work that goes
into getting the getting the service
right for our local residents clearly
transparency will mean we'll continue to
keep a close eye on the service that
we're is going to be delivered for our
residents and clearly there are
opportunities to members to feedback in
future whether it be for exclusively
committee or whether it be indeed
through Council or through the executive
but with that I think this is good news
and I am happy to move the um move the
recommendations set out as one to four
in this part of the agenda part one of
all those in favor
thank you very much so if we move on to
something
um completely different now which is the
item seven and it's personal delivery
devices uh councilor ad said thank you
yeah
that lightweight something that's really
good news
positive
ly
it's actually really uh out loud
yeah so basically uh because you may
recall the commence delivery robots in
the spring would be fair to say uh
obviously really positive Community it's
clearly obviously learn something like
this is first introduced as a normality
effect and when that in itself actually
helps promote that this is
useful it is and actually the daily
Bible
yeah well
much to say really on a regular notebook
and indeed you can just get this uh
personal cooler video service physical
options look at that which actually
helps to fill a gap in the moment uh
that isn't there and I don't know if you
know about the helps with sustainability
their whole production carbons so I
think if you're really welcome to
generate jobs and it's really been
deceived I think only was talked about
it through the positive news story and
especially I think most almost social
media for a chance to actually positive
which makes change results from media
because I mean the kids love these those
who don't know at times at Christmas
each of these robots will be given a
name relations a particular name there
so that's your normal glasses from them
robots
[Music]
when it comes thank you
thank you characterizes one just initial
question for me are we going to have any
kind of name competitions like voting
both face no Richard's okay any
questions or comments from ASAP members
counselors later
some jobs within that sector but it's
quite clear from the evidence that it's
been produced if that hasn't happened so
obviously it's within a gap in the
market so with police that you know
we're looking at it again from another
six months
thank you councils later
any further comments I'll go to council
wants me first
um just uh wondering if the bone and
Avail Co-op was considered it doesn't
seem to be on the list for the next
round and I'm just wondering if it's
just too hilly or it might be a
potential in the future
I've been saying is that simply I've
come across these occasions and yeah
[Music]
foreign
liability over there
within this but uh and he's qualified
what would happen in that situation you
suddenly broke the leg and started
their their personal delivery uh devices
they're not they're not Vehicles they're
able to go on to do it and they are very
very risk uh first so they will stop if
they see uh anything uh so any movement
to their turn to stop they stopped
across the road they know their Green
Cross Court so they are very risk-averse
should there be a public liability
insurance is with the company not with
Google Authority so it is different to
we uh scooters which are not
today then these scooters are not
permitted to be used
try it
and this is the quick problem was just
to uh talk about the
greatest
um
thank you Council voters any other
questions
oh Council Holden
not really the question or a comment
about these different verses
um
they are not only
effectively music they are agonizingly
polite I came across you and have done a
nose dive
from the curb and was on its head on its
front with its wheels in the air
completely unable to move
I picked it up close it back on its
Wheels it tumbled away and suddenly
stopped and said thank you
it really is
so let's not mix these up with the
electric scooters and the obviously
[Music]
well thank you Council Holden for that
ringing endorsement tomorrow delivery
devices that
um so I mean again they've served a good
purpose in the trial we've um they've
the advice have said almost 10 000
households in that period there's been a
reduction of over a thousand kilograms
of CO2 emissions from it and a reduction
in probably 2 600 uh vehicle miles in
that time so they are very effective and
I think the the residents of Southwest
in that area have to take them to their
hearts uh during that trial and I do
hope the residents have typically at
Ernst and do the same so the
recommendations are set out as eight D
in the report all those in favor
thank you very much
so if we move on to item 8 which is the
approval of the tree management policy
and Council asset again
it's an interview
strategy foreign
you always get that from consultations
in my view and how to cancel it it's
obviously
through this quality and takes halfway
to Sky practice and obviously given
climate change their ability
and naturally please continue and play a
demi course of part in all of this and
obviously not to be affect that climate
change itself actually and its extremes
of weather actually has an effect on
what they're treated to complete it's
obviously getting this sort of type
report is right you will know of course
that one of the major changes
is
[Music]
any comments or questions from the
executive
any further comments or questions
thanks we welcome a lot of this report
uh it's got one um additional uh
question regarding uh we had a visit
from the Britain In Bloom judge in
Georgian recently and he pointed out
that um uh one traffic staff were
causing damage to some of some of the
local trees through the streaming
um and uh and mowing too close to the
trees particularly for shallow rooting
trees like um like cherry trees that can
be quiet
um quite damaging to them I was
wondering if the tree unit could be
involved in future is heading standards
of tree care for the one trafficked
staff to follow and could this include a
recommendation for grass and this was
what the judge was suggesting for
granting he left longer around the base
of the trees where appropriate
um so that you know your people working
through staff weren't tempted to screw
night up to the tree or mow right next
to the tree to preserve the root face
raising it
situations and circumstances and you
stop at the response times will be uh
realistic uh and avoided by
all I can say counters out there
performance like I believe I'm not aware
of that particularly timings in that
sense
foreign
refugees from Ukraine and Afghanistan
this plan utilizes existing buildings
nothing new so enables them to be
brought up to a good residential
standard it provides much needed
continued accommodation for refugees
learning more and persecution
[Music]
on the housing register in Trafford and
in the long term these properties become
Council stock and enhance our temporary
accommodation which I'm sure everyone is
not needed
I will just address another concern
um that's come up over the last week as
well in relation to rack and the the
concrete that we've all known in the
years and it was uh to be honestly
they're a real shame to see the liberal
Democrat group the one that's the local
press on receiving the briefing with the
central councilors on the discovery of
Iraq and the reference Center across
five
uh the sensible and my eyesight most
constructive approach
the Civic Assurance is directly from the
executive or offices
I'm not clear how this has helped anyone
including any risk of misguiding
political gang they thought they might
desirely benefit from
and on that note I'm happy to provide
those assurances tonight as followers
the council were aware of Racket Cross
Banking 2020 and this signal has been
propped and made some safe since then
the rack a Grafton was discovered during
the survey work in the summer
the plan is drafted for both properties
remove the rack in the properties and
replace the roofs there was never a
question of not replacing the rack this
is part of the plan works and as per the
report we are still waiting problem
surveys but we'll be in a position to
commit planning at the end of September
subjects are exactly to approval
tonight's meeting thank you Jeff
thank you councilor right um I
completely agree this is this is a good
news story with regards to housing and
it's going to good purpose and once the
once that purpose has come to an end we
will keep the stock and be able to use
it uh as temporary accommodation so I do
work with that clearly with rack it has
caused a lot of concern for a lot of
people across the country in weeks and
we have to be very careful about how we
inform the public
we were already as a council looking and
that's an investigating areas and and
providing updates members so I also
share your disappointment at the reports
that came out via the local Democrats on
that I don't think it helps anyone
are there any other questions or
comments counselor to tell
also welcome this report I think it's a
really positive
um proposition here and I think it's
another example of where I'm Trafford
punches above its weight requires for
national funding secures that and
delivers for its local residents and
it's a clever use of investment into our
existing assets to repurpose them and I
think it will be a really significant
boost long term to our local supported
and temporary accommodation the cost of
which
um our crippling local councils up and
down the country I would just share your
disappointment at the very very poor
headlines locally last week whilst um
scrutiny is obviously important to go to
the Press
share and baselist concerns
um for some sort of political gain it's
really very very poor and I know that
officers were very disappointed officers
that have done a lot of hard work into
this proposition we're very disappointed
that it was implied that that we were at
any point considering housing residents
in dangerous conditions which is
absolutely not not the case and never
will be thank you thank you councilor
Patel any other questions from the
executive okay uh Council Welton first
thank you leader um as we are very much
look forward to welcoming these new
residents um
this goes through uh planning and having
them to my Town Center door knocking
around
um just wondering if I have highways I
had a look at the The graft on the site
yet and have they expressed any concerns
I think oh that's still to come as part
of the planning process
clearly my questions are around the rap
briefing that the council provided and
can I just say at the crossbank site in
Hermiston it was clear that whilst it
was discovered was also made safe but
the wording on the Grafton Mall site in
Algerian there's no mention about being
made safe so there's clearly more work
to do to make the units of Grafton safe
and do we know how that will impact on
the planets how do you train your napkin
refugees at that Summit
uh
yeah thanks cancer I mean if you have
written uh to myself I haven't really so
I will confirm that and so I I would
happily receive that what happens
um in relation to uh the racket where I
could Grafton
um it's in the process we would of
course never housed anyone let alone
refugees in an unsafe building and the
rack will be remedied well before any
any queue would be losing to that
particular building so that's who made
clear this evening by myself
as well thank you
okay uh customer and this did you want
to just come back really free chair I
asked specifically about time standing
in relationship proposals to Ukrainian
African refugees into Unity to make
clear just now but I cancel around it
could be
I hope that helps I think that's very
clear councilor right
um did I see some yes councilor evidence
thank you chair that was seven questions
this will deliver a major change to one
of our main High Street destinations and
our council's Investment Portfolio got
no critique of the overall plans as far
as Refugee residency our group support
for both coverts my personal support for
Ukraine is well documented over the past
three years
now and knowledge the council's got no
overall plan to do anything with that
end of altering them it's all about the
grapplins for about two years
last time maybe the time before this end
of the high streets in particular need
of support there are more and more empty
units so
of the 10 flats that are being delivered
how many commercial units are we losing
and what is the pronoun for part two
what is the commercial rent loss this
would lead to and because that would
need offsetting against the potential
gains claiming party I'll take that
answer in part two more questions
and potentially 8 million which is in
this report for 29 units although 10 are
within our own property so potentially
we've got cost per unit 320 to 421 000
pounds per unit
how can this be just be found
I've got two more our investment now
into the graph there's a portion of that
eight million will that be written off
in two years time when the Grafton comes
up for a proper regeneration
and finally the grafting stands on our
balance sheet at 10 million that's in
the public domain from its purchase in
2017. as I've noted in our annual
account I've not seen a revaluation ever
and
how will this change the effect on its
overall value within our Investment
Portfolio as residential doesn't attract
the same valuation gearing as commercial
properties has that been taken into
consideration and then sorry one more
similar to the rack has the ongoing
asbestos issues being addressed and is
that covered within the ambulance that
were proposing spending which will cover
it up to if necessary
okay at this point I will pass to
Richard to see which bits he would like
to answer now which because he can't
answer now and which bits will be
answered in part two Richard
convert
the commercial units will talk about the
converting are the ones on the first uh
flying around where they were talking
about is so they're not ones that have
been used as commercial units at any
point since we were there our storage
space we're not losing any retail
unitary units that we would intend to
have let out as retail units so there's
no effect on the valuation that are
renting the graphics as a result so this
is purely additive
uh
any aspects that is identifiers will be
cleared out and has been factored in
that's part of the first broadcast
that's why we have the survey that's
been done to identified the right
refurbished the the Grafton Center is
now I think for the letter we've got
funds interfully right other than the
central other than the internal uh
the rest of the references
okay
um
right so no other questions so
recommendations are set out in the
report one to four all those in favor
thank you very much let me move on to
item 10 which is uh the street trading
designated streets policy and fees and
introduced counselor Rose Thompson thank
you Jim currently traffic Council does
not have an overarching Street trading
policy rather the council has a list of
prohibited streets guidance notes
conditions and agreed fees what should
not be reviewed for many many years
therefore earlier this year it's decided
to do our decision making processes and
be charged and produce an up-to-date
completely policy
we wanted to bring in into the policy
there was people that trade on private
land often in their Gardens you call
they do not require to hold a license or
consent this usually occurs mainly
around Manchester United ground on the
cricket ground on Match days and events
this proposed policy was produced with
support the other nine GM authorities
and brings us into line with them this
policy introduces new zone areas so an a
around Manchester United on the prickly
ground where a trading license will be
required and zones BNC sale and Ultra
all Freedom where a consent will be
needed we'll also be retaining a list of
prohibited streets which are almost
suitable for Street Trading
as a result these new zones and the
simply caps and the simplification of
the payment regime I'm happy to say that
Visa trading in zone a can now be
reduced by 50
and there's only a tiny increase to the
of the other areas which is great use of
businesses who've been hard hit by the
cost of business rise running costs of
business in those few years
regarding Charities morality secretary
and Community benefits societies who
apply to trade they will not be required
to pay the fees or they although they
were still subject to the same effective
procedures
as we as with those trading on private
land the protection and safety of our
residents and visitors is an important
part of the policy
this policy does not have any impact on
our street fairs and markets which are
not deemed to be Street Trading
if approved this policy will come into
effect on the 1st of December this year
the policy will be kept under review and
we will make amendments as necessary and
the fees will be reviewed annually
in conclusion I hope you're out in this
new policy and I believe which I believe
is longer overdue I also want to thank
the licensing team especially John Boyle
and Claire Whittle where their dedicated
dedicated work on this it's a good piece
of work that ensures our street trading
practices and procedures are up to date
on paper purpose thank you
thank you councilor Thompson and I Echo
your thanks up to our officers who have
pulled this together where we didn't
have a policy before are there any
questions or comments from executive
members
any wider questions comments Council
Welton
thanks I think this is a good piece of
work and again very very helpful for
this area around around here uh
currently our street program down in the
south of the Borrowers is to do with the
chuggers and charity collectors which
you I think you're probably aware we've
had some problems with recently I look
forward to a future piece of work on
that is that going forward
foreign
basis only as you've said councilor
Thompson the thesis in zone a was
significantly reduced and fees are
exempt for Charities and Community
benefits societies as well so what we're
doing here is recommending noting the
report and recommending the policy to
council all those in favor
thank you and if we move on now to the
budget monitoring report for period four
and cancel
thank you leader
um I put before you period for Budget
monitoring report to recommend that note
the report particularly no TV those
expand denote the update on the capital
program
um to note some of the management
actions that are currently in place to
mitigate the current projected overspend
um it is the detailed report I would
prefer members to page 269 which talks
in more detail really about the
uncertainty and the challenges that
local governments face particularly in
relation to interest rates inflation and
the challenges that all local government
faced I'm sure each and every one of you
would have seen the news over recent
weeks I don't think any local Authority
is protected from some of the challenges
that are heading
um way what I will say is that the
executive are working really closely
with the officers I've been working with
and I had a meeting this afternoon with
counselor Carter and children's offices
to look in more detail because as you
can see some of the significant
challenges that local authorities are
facing are in children's it is a
national so
clear that all levels are worried about
how do we protect our most vulnerable
residents but also how do we prevent
young people ending up in the care
system in the first place so lots of
work is going on in children's also the
high needs block and special educational
needs so clearly the areas of interest
for me as the portfolio holder and the
why you're exec how to look at how we
mitigate some of those challenges that
we face in local government so I take a
report to know thank you Nina
thank you councilor Harding are there
any questions or comments from the
executive
any further questions councilor but
thank you chair uh we recognize the uh
the costs involved with the children
services I thought there's just a few
points I wanted to pick up on in other
things it's just in fact the the
planning and being conjured for 463 000
is running
that that was anticipated but uh why it
has been such a shortfall in that
anonymously what is the actual the
reserve for the business creates that
you have
walked up
um
which I think in relation to the
planning but I think the reserves are
all outlined in the report you can
escape the the different pots that we
have for business rates moving reserves
councils that were clarified out of the
grade
first of all the people
uh yeah
income is always something of a
challenge it's a demand right and we
encourage development in the world as
far as we are able to do so is we do
keep them close
okay yeah
and you've always wanted to understand
what level of reserves we have to in
relation to business rights yeah
really before
it's not there's no specific reference I
think whether they recall to talk about
the reviews we've built and Incorporated
technology
performance okay the business
and this one final question if I'm here
it's just that uh honest is I don't know
the increase in income 2.24 million and
increased interest rates uh how much is
invested in fixed interest accessories
are you on a particular page there
Council just identify the
um that's in the treasury management
the return to the generator for cash
balance are all fixed interest rates
with the short-term investment interest
prevailing Investments
thank you thank you Council Hardy thank
you Graham um clearly
Local Government funding has been in the
news quite a lot recently
um with several councils predicting
quite significant overspans in year most
of that as councilor Harding suggests is
around the children's placements area
um
we will see and we will ask our
conservative colleagues to Prevail on
the government when it comes to the
settlement not just for councils like
was it Trafford but for other councils
across the country to make sure that we
get the funding that we need to deliver
the services that the public expect from
us but clearly even in these difficult
times you have our assurance that we
will continue to work incredibly closely
with our officers to deliver a balanced
budget this item is for noting can I
accept that as being noted thank you
very much so now
go on to the original business of which
I have none so it is now time for me to
do the exclusion resolution which Alex
will now make me read out together so I
will put my teeth in that the public we
excluded from the meeting during the
consideration of the remaining items
of the likelihood of disclosure and
accept information which Falls within
one or more descriptive category or
categories of the local government 1972
schedule 12a as then amended by the
local government access to information
variation order 2006 and specified on
the agenda item or report related to
each such item respectively there we go
so can I ask people public to now leave
the
thank you very much and thank you for
your attendance